Chicago's new mayor is taking on
political corruption in her first
official act Lori Lightfoot signed an
executive order yesterday that limits
the power of Chicago's City Council
members she's the first african-american
woman and first openly LGBTQ person to
lead her city Lightfoot spoke with CTM
national correspondent
Jericka Duncan in her first national
interview as mayor jury good morning
good morning she definitely has a lot on
her plate but she says she is ready
former prosecutor is now running the
nation's third largest city Democrat
Lori Lightfoot says her priorities
include public public safety education
and tackling the city's forty two
billion dollar debt well to succeed
she'll have to take on Chicago's
political machine and she'll be doing it
as an outsider you're introduced many
times as the first female
african-american openly gay mayor of
Chicago does that bother you at all no
no it's a great testament to I think the
spirit of our city in a moment that
we're in I'm honored that people of the
city look beyond labels and voted for me
five foot one in Chicago Mayor Lori
Lightfoot is known to have an outsized
ability to fight something she says she
learned from her 90 year old mother
she's my role model a champion who was
there to witness her daughter's historic
inauguration Monday for me to come from
where I come from with my family's
heritage and the sacrifices that both of
my parents made it means everything that
she was here to witness this moment a
moment that was realized on April 2nd
when Lightfoot declared victory
President Trump did call you to
congratulate you what was that
conversation like between you and
President Trump what was very cordial
does it bother you to see the city
criticized by the President on Twitter
when it comes to gun violence
of course how do you work with a
president who says he wants to work with
you but has definitely gone on his
Twitter account and criticized Chicago
in the gun violence what the hell is
going on in Chicago well look my values
are not of his values on a range of
different issues but I think that I have
an
Legation to a residents of the city
particularly the taxpayers to do
everything I can to make sure that we
get our fair share of dollars from
Washington DC Lightfoot rose to
political prominence after chairing a
police accountability task force in the
wake of the deadly 2014 police shooting
of teenager laQuan McDonald it led to
citywide protests national anger and a
murder conviction against the officer
who shot him 40 we have been embarked on
what I would call a proactive strategy
that looks at our gun violence as a
public health crisis which is what it is
that means we look at the root causes of
the violence that means we invest in
neighborhoods we re stitch together our
broken social safety but what does
invest in neighborhoods mean what does
that means that we bring resources to
communities so that they can grow that
we work on providing wraparound services
and job training in the neighborhoods
that are under siege and economically
distressed you talked a lot about this
coming down to communities trusting
police and the police also trusting the
communities how do you bridge that gap
police can't be successful if they're
not viewed as legitimate by the
community and the community will not be
safe if the police are not engaged in a
respectful constitutional partnership
with the community and the only way to
do it is person by person there's no
magic solution
she says her biggest fear is seeing
children who feel quote pinned down by
gun violence but she is extremely
optimistic saying she hopes to see a
decrease in gun violence as early as
this summer and it wasn't just a
historic day for Lightfoot for the first
time in Chicago's history women of color
now hold three city wide elected offices
as you can see right there it's pretty
she came in an extraordinary wave of
support because she won every ward in
the city she sure did lovely to see her
mother there at the ceremony aged 90
because I've got a brother right who's
been in out of prison how does that
color her politic yeah we asked her that
question about how does that inform your
decisions and she basically said that
she's focused on making sure there are
adequate re-entry programs because you
have thousands of people from the prison
systems going into the streets that
she's trying to
help and save so very optimistic we look
forward to following up to see what Haga
looks like a year from now she's been
very candid and transparent about it
most thing about everything so far in
her life it she's made it clear there
gonna be some changes around here in
Chicago it'll be interesting to see how
that turns out for her thank you for
Rica thank you very much